en fait les valises les films sont
terribles éviter comme les mythes et
hystérique rhodésie futur radieux un
petit comme un héros chine radioactifs
comme à nagasaki marqué lundi avec
quelques détails à novalima drones
vaisseau spatial il était là pour
prendre du plaisir l'abbé drôme ces
trois jeunes âgés de 16 à 18 ans un
groupe passionné de rap français et us
du rap actuel
on rappelle en fait surtout dans la cour
du collège on aimait bien quoi et
et puis un jour on était au lycée moi
j'avais arrêté j'avais arrêté c'était
une époque où j'avais fait une pause
dans les cours et je les appelais un
jour et juliette était chaud pour un
groupe et il m'a dit oui tout de suite
et du coup on a commencé comme ça c'est
gros participer au tremplin franciliens
première scène un concours mais aussi
parfois une première scène pour ces
jeunes groupes
[Musique]
demain
c
on a toujours été attiré par joue de la
musique devant un peu mal de monde puis
on trouvait que on a vu le tremplin sur
les réseaux sociaux
francis était en petite hausse 1 pas de
participer jeu pour nous de mettre un
petit challenge avec le groupe
et puis après après vingt pour que notre
famille et puissent venir aussi première
scène est destiné aux lycéens
franciliens depuis trois ans rock en
seine et la région ile de france donne
leur chance à la jeunesse
c'est une opportunité pour des gens qui
aiment la musique qu'on monte un groupe
de voir ce que ça peut être finalement
que qu'un festival que jouer dans des
conditions professionnelles parce que ce
sera leur premier cachet et puis on va
leur apprendre cet été ce que c'est une
feuille technique du bac live la démo
qui peuvent paraître un petit peu
technique mais c'est une approche en
douceur
les sélections se déroule sur cette
scène ouverte francilienne depuis le
mois de mars
en attendant pour les ovins coeur de
jouer en août en live un rock en seine
[Musique]